eight-year-old Mihaly has been taking
part in beauty pageants since she was
two years old
preparation takes hours kicking off with
a spray tan who is that in that picture
me you're very different it's your glitz
do you like being glitz yes Mihaly
almost manages to sit still long enough
for full makeup to be applied the
Hayley's mum she loves the pageant world
she insists her daughter loves it too
sharee says it gives Mihaly confidence
I'm a perfectionist oh now we're talking
pact this is what she calls her tribute
to America outfit but there's a problem
she thinks her hat fits weird but it's a
pant so it's the part of the outfit
remember you only wearing it for 5
minutes and you're not jumping around it
shines baby doll it's Texas
[Music]
little girls of all ages take part
it's estimated that quarter of a million
children competes in more than 5,000
pageants in the United States each year
this one's organizer insists appearance
isn't everything but critics argue this
simply isn't healthy for young girls the
long-term impact of what this means
psychologically for kids the
over-reliance and how you look in the
teen years this might turn into an
eating disorder if you think being Miley
Cyrus or Britney Spears or someone like
that is a goal and that's your way to a
better life then this is a great
training ground parents spend thousands
of dollars making sure they get exactly
the right look Mihaly did get a trophy
but it wasn't for first place I think
that I've got perfect with hair and
makeup dress and then when you don't win
that you have to wonder what did I do
wrong the celebrity culture of
appearance over substance is fuelling
the dreams of Fame in this world of
miniature ball gowns and false lashes
the quest for perfection continues as
each little girl tries to find her place
in the spotlight Amanda Walker Sky News
Austin Texas